[Musique]
il ya près de nancy dans cette résidence
de l'université laval un homme entré en
pleine nuit dans les chambres de leur
femme pour les agresser un rassemblement
visant à soutenir les glycines de la fin
de semaine dernière face à 12 chefs
d'accusation et le mode hot soir était
on vous voit s'en est suivie une
sérieuse réflexion sur les violences
sexuelles sur la culture du viol à la
veille de la rentrée universitaire et
des initiations
j'ai rencontré la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur pour savoir ce
qu'il souhaite faire pour prévenir ces
violences hurler quand on en dise il
garde dans le sens où on fait du
n'importe quoi des initiations par 100
votants on conduisait une moto qui avait
la bière et de jean un obscur et là on
est rendu et non ça marche une main
c'est concret l'instruction et le début
d'une action dimanche vous avez mené
cinq jaunes consultation qu'est ce que
vous avez appris au cours de la dernière
saison j'ai compris que les victimes ne
devait plus jamais être laissé seul à
elle-même jeunes et des témoignages qui
vous en bourse
ce qui est bouleversant et il ajoute
parle comme comme femme je vous parle
comme merde
les victimes qui est on n'a pas idée des
fois des ravages vraiment des ravages
que ça peut faire un membre très très
nombreuses années que une grande
préoccupation par rapport à la
sensibilisation qu'est ce que c'est que
la consentement sexuel
bernard de rome avait un vidéo
extraordinaire j'espère que vous l'avez
vu imaginez qu'au lieu d'initier un acte
sexuel vous prépariez du thé vous iriez
aimerais-tu une tasse de thé avoir fait
douter ne signifie pas que vous avez
gagné le droit de la voir boire vous
allez présenter une stratégie
qu'est ce qui va changer sur toutes les
initiations are in france quels domaines
les administrations universitaires se
sont dit eux qui n'ont pas bien goût
d'être dans un journal pour toutes
sortes d'activités ou dont on n'est pas
très fier et je pense qu'elle prenne des
mesures déjà fort intéressant ce que tu
ais je le fais c'est que tout le québec
tous les établissements d'enseignement
stoner prenne des mesures depuis le
triste événement l'université laval le
centre d'aidé et de lutte contre les
agressions à caractère sexuel de large
le québec a connu un bond de 50% des
victimes réclamant de l'aide les deux
tiers avaient moins de 24 ans donc une
jeune femme ça lui arrive pouet se peut
le faire même sur le campus c'est mon
souhait le plus simple c'est de
permettre si de d'avoir une sorte de
guichet unique par exemple on peut
accompagner ont pu la lire ou poste de
police avec toi parce qu'il ya toutes
ces questions trop souvent ce bolide
allait l'être avant tous les
renseignements mais c'est pas tout le
monde qui voit les mesures non ça peut
être simplement écouter ensuite capable
est en présence de cette personne là
habité qui est victime croise par hasard
son prochain départ avant c'est
difficile parce que le siège de la rue
saint denis à travers pourrait bien
l'être en plus il ya moyen de faire le
maximum en reconnaissant dans le même
programme ski ça ça donne finalement un
groupe de travail on a on a un travail
d'équipé à faire je pourrais tu changes
et de 2 2 où il pourrait tout changer
lui de béquilles aps
sauf que de la sensibilité académique
qui va falloir développer et que j'en
aurai revanche l'entraîneur est vrai que
le rapport
bon voilà le mot croyez vraiment cela
remet en cause sa wii et puis 9 reste le
justement d'avoir une stratégie pour les
collèges les unissent avec toutes les
consultations ça montre qu'ils ont un
intérêt évident la ministre va déposer
un projet de loi à l'automne mais ce
plan d'action qu'en pensez vous donnez
nous votre avis dans la section
commentaire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]